Today, we're going to be speaking to John
Mark Hansen, who's a professor in political
science at the University of Chicago.
We are going to talk a little bit about what
would it look like to rig and or steal an
American presidential election.
Mark, it's great to have you on.
Thank you.
It's great to be here.
So, OK.
I mean, at this point, I don't think we have
to rehash all of the claims that were made
between November 4th and January 6th or January
20th or even up until today and continue to
be made.
Let's just get into the reality.
So so maybe the audience can understand what
would go into this.
Could could an American presidential election,
which is really 50 state elections, could
it be rigged?
Could it be stolen?
How would it have to be done if so?
Well, I would say that it's difficult to the
point of impossible, I think many people just
don't understand the scale of the effort that
would be involved to actually fix a presidential
election.
You're not talking about a few hundred votes.
You're not talking about a few thousand votes.
You're talking about tens or even hundreds
of thousands of votes spread along a number
of states.
So there are folks who will say, well, you
know, 80 million votes versus 75 million or
whatever.
You don't really need to flip millions of
votes.
You really need.
For example, in 2016, it was 77000 votes in
three states.
In twenty twenty it was depending on how you
slice it, about 100000 votes.
That's very different than million.
So that presumably would make it simpler.
Simpler, but not by any means simple, if you
imagine what it would take to shift a number
of votes and bear in mind that you don't know
exactly where the problem is going to be,
you don't know exactly what the margin you
need is and you don't know exactly where it's
going to be.
So you have to start months in advance and
you have to be thinking in terms of tens of
thousands of votes and you have to be thinking
about how it is that you would recruit tens
of thousands of people to participate in this
effort without anybody blowing the whistle
on you.
OK, so let me play devil's advocate.
Maybe you don't need to recruit tens of thousands
if you can just get a few tech people who,
quote, control the voting machines, that might
be a simple way.
And you might only need five or six people.
Well, that is the case, however, you still
have to maintain a conspiracy of those five
or six people, and one of the things we know
is it's very difficult to maintain conspiracies.
So there are many, many business frauds that
go awry or criminal frauds or criminal activities
that go awry because people feel the need
to say something either because they want
to boast about it or because they have a guilty
conscience or whatever.
So you would have to you would have to have
a great deal of trust in your Confederate's.
But even beyond that, there are lots and lots
and lots of barriers have been erected to
actually manipulating the vote in that way.
There are security measures for the technology
that's used in voting and vote counting.
And moreover, there's the knowledge of the
there's a knowledge of the people who are
overseeing the voting process.
And so at some county comes in all of a sudden
with ten thousand more votes than they've
ever cast before, someone might say, boy,
that looks kind of fishy.
Maybe we ought to look closer at that.
There are so many different claims that have
been made about mechanisms for subterfuge,
some of which conflict with each other.
And maybe I don't know how much we need to
necessarily get into that.
But just to talk about a few of the different
things, there's, as I mentioned, the idea
of simply using hacking skills to change the
vote tallies of a group of voting machines.
We heard stories of so-called massive dumps
of ballots coming in in the middle of the
night on vans and literally just taking boxes
of ballots out, which presumably in that case,
the voting machines aren't being manipulated,
but someone's feeding in a bunch of ballots.
There's the idea of having election workers
look at ballots and then disqualify only some,
presumably to help one candidate and hurt
the other.
All of these are based on different principles.
And what to me seems very difficult would
be that you might end up with one of these
strategies working against the different one.
Conflicting the coordination of such strategies
seems extraordinarily difficult.
Yeah, it's it's enormously difficult.
Take take, for instance, the idea of a bunch
of ballots that get dumped.
So most states, most jurisdictions, in fact,
allow partizan observers to ballot counting.
And so all of a sudden these ballots come
in and someone might say, so where do they
come from?
How do we know that they're authentic?
There should be a mark on the ballot.
There should be some kind of record that the
person at the polling place actually authorize
this person to vote or if it's an absentee
ballot, should meet the requirements for absentee
ballots, which oftentimes include a signature.
They include a ballot application, all kinds
of things.
So there are all kinds of safeguards to prevent
ballots from being submitted fraudulently
and certainly all kinds of safeguards to make
sure that if there are frauds, there's a likelihood
of their being discovered, particularly on
a large scale.
Yeah, when it comes to in-person voter fraud,
the idea of someone I don't even know, sometimes
it's not even clear to me exactly how you
would do it.
You would go to multiple polling places or
show up and claim to be a variety of different
people.
I mean, you wouldn't be registered in multiple
places.
So going to polling places as you wouldn't
wouldn't work.
I guess you could show up and say at one polling
place you say you're Joe Smith, and at the
next play you say you say you're Steve Johnson
and that type of thing.
But it seems like in order to flip 50000 votes
with that strategy, you need thousands of
people making it incredibly unlikely to be
able to do it secretly.
Exactly.
Just think about recruiting such a number
of people.
So somehow you're going to have to find a
bunch of people who are willing to take the
risk either to their freedom or to their pocketbook
or to their reputations to participate in
all of this.
And you're going to have to make sure that
you don't reach anybody who has a healthy
enough conscience that they would blow the
whistle on you when it comes to people getting
caught attempting to do these things from
looking at the Brennan Center for Justice
work on this, which is looked at over a billion
votes over.
I don't I don't know how many years, many,
many years.
They say that this in-person voter fraud is
not only extremely rare, but there is not
even a single case in which it has come close
to actually affecting the outcome of of a
race.
There are people who will claim, maybe cynically,
maybe not, that just because the Brennan Center
gives us these numbers, it doesn't address
the number of people that are getting away
with it, which simply don't show up.
When you hear about, oh, 20 people were caught
trying to do this, how can we defeat the idea
that maybe there are lots of people not caught?
Doing it.
Well, again, I think the you have to kind
of do the math on it, so any kind of large
scale effort means that the difficulties go
up, the costs go up and the risk of exposure
goes up.
The more people who are involved in this,
the more votes that are involved in this,
the greater the likelihood that it's going
to be found.
So, yeah, maybe there are people who get away
with it, but there are people who get away
with it, maybe affecting one or two votes.
You know, out of all the scrutiny that this
last election got so far, the only indictment
that we've seen for any kind of voting irregularities
was a man in Pennsylvania who voted an absentee
ballot for his mother.
Right.
For Donald Trump.
So that's that's the typical kind of thing
that we see in these cases, most cases of
voter fraud or alleged voter fraud or not
even prosecuted because it's people making
honest mistakes.
They thought that they were registered, but
they weren't where they thought that they
were eligible in this jurisdiction, but they
weren't or so forth.
So most of these cases have quite innocent
explanations.
What would be of all of these different mechanisms?
What's the one you're most likely to get away
with?
Oh, boy, I'm not sure that there are that
many possibilities anymore, you know, back
in the bad old days, there used to be a fair
bit of vote for it was committed both by Republicans
and by Democrats.
And as a result of that, election, officials
learned through time what those what those
frauds look like.
And they learned about how to take security
measures to make sure that those frauds didn't
occur.
And so by now, with a century of experience
with the Australian ballot, with the secret
ballot, we have lots and lots of experience
in this.
And it's not like people have just been twiddling
their thumbs and saying, oh, I when they encounter
problems, they've taken steps to avoid them
in the future.
When it comes to the U.S. having these 50
election systems plus D.C., I guess you'd
say, you know, it's fifty one election systems.
One could make the argument that the election
is less secure because you have so many different
systems.
But on the other hand, you could make the
argument that having all of these systems
actually makes it more secure, because in
order to really do some kind of fraud at a
at a big level, you'd have to figure out a
way to manipulate multiple different systems.
Do you think that having the 51 different
systems on balance makes the election more
or less secure?
That's a good question.
I think you could argue it both ways.
Certainly one could argue that if you have
separate systems, you might not have all jurisdictions
adopting best practices, and that would be
an argument for a more uniform system.
On the other hand, if it is a matter of some
kind of technical expertize to manipulate
these systems, then having a wide variety
of systems means that you have to have a greater
variety of technical expertize in order to
do anything significant.
Do you think that because of all of the the
smears that we've heard over the last two
or three months about the election of twenty
twenty, there's going to be a skepticism about
the system in some parts among some communities
that will last a long time?
Or is it as simple as if in twenty twenty
two politicians don't make these claims, people
will, generally speaking, trust the systems
again.
Well, I think that there is now a partizan
reason not to, quote unquote trust the system,
whether that actually translates into people
behaving in a different way, I think is another
question entirely.
There are all these concerns in Georgia, for
instance, in the Senate runoff that the Donald
Trump's casting aspersions on the fairness
of the Georgia election would mean that Republicans
would stay home.
Why right.
Then they definitely lose.
Right.
Why would you do that?
So so I'm skeptical that it will matter a
whole lot.
What it what it does do, however, is to raise
the possibility of just casting doubt on the
legitimacy of every election outcome.
And that's a bad thing.
Yeah.
And that it seems I mean, I there was a woman
who confronted Mitt Romney in an airport a
couple of weeks ago.
And almost like as a reflexive thing, she
said you weren't your election wasn't even
legitimate.
And like who?
I didn't even know the Utah twenty eighteen
election was being challenged in terms of
its legitimate legitimacy.
It seems it's becoming a catchall for.
I don't like that you won.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
And this has been brewing for a while.
It's been a Republican strategy since 2010,
basically to elect more, to erect more and
more and more barriers to the voting and particularly
to the constituencies that tend to vote Democratic
just in order to keep one's opponents away
from the polls.
Right.
So, you know, this is actually and in that
respect, the twenty twenty election was something
of an embarrassment because we had easier
access to voting than we've ever had before
in our history.
And we have a whistle clean election.
So now what are they going to claim?
Right.
How how can they how can they say, well, actually,
things do work.
And so we get a doubling down on these fraud
claims.
Yeah.
And in fact, Christopher Krebs, who worked
for Donald Trump, said exactly that.
It was fine and he was fired.
And so we see the political nature that it's
taking on.
We've been speaking with Professor John Mark
Hanson, who teaches political science at the
University of Chicago.
So great having you on today.
I really appreciate it.
It's been fun.
Thank you.